okay let's address something head-on
just to do it and get it out of the way
for future segments last week and in
other segments I've made an effort to
remind the audience that I'm completely
fine covering instances of right-wing
violence based on politics and of
left-wing political violence and that we
shouldn't be hypocrites we shouldn't
hide left-wing violence to the extent
that it exists but when I do those
stories I will remind you that it's
important to remember that most
politically oriented violence in the
United States is right-wing it's
important to remind you of that not for
some kind of what about ism but because
if we really want to deal with the issue
of political violence as an apparatus in
the United States as a problem we have
to understand where it comes from and it
mostly comes from the right most
religious violence in the United States
is from right-wingers so let's actually
dig into that and the way we know things
is through studying data and there are
countless ways that you can come to the
same conclusion so let's go through some
of the sources I'm sure many of you will
have problems with some of these sources
which is why I'm presenting a number of
different ones let's start with the
anti-defamation league the
anti-defamation league has studied this
for a very long time their latest report
is from 2018 which makes sense since
we're in 2019 right now and it is on
domestic extremists murder 50 of 50
people killed in 2018 were because of
right-wing extremism 78 percent were
white supremacists 16% were
anti-government extremists 4% were insel
extremists and 2% meaning one guy was an
Islamist extremist now we can argue over
whether Islamist extremism is left or
right wing the right loves to say
Islamist extremism is left-wing because
Muslims
I guess often don't like Republicans
this is extraordinarily simplistic and
short-sighted religious belief to a
degree that you become radicalized is by
nature a right-wing perversion of
religion but we can ignore it and we can
say 49 of 50 2018
domestic extremist murders were
definitely right-wing extreme
1 out of 50 I guess we can debate uh uh
the the specifics of it that's the
anti-defamation league now I know some
of you dislike the ADL or you don't
trust the ADL so let's go to another set
of data the CSIs the Center for
Strategic and International Studies
they've identified that indeed the
overwhelming majority of violence from
extremists in the United States is
coming from white supremacists
anti-government extremists including
militias and so-called sovereign
citizens groups very very clear on the
data some of you will say David I don't
like the ADL and I don't like CSIS well
then you've got the data from the Center
for Investigative Reporting who also
looked at this from 2008 to 2016 and
they found 115 right-wing terror
incidents 63 Islamist inspired terror
incidents and 19 left-wing incidents so
if you include radical Islam as
right-wing which I do it is almost 91
percent right-wing if you consider
Islamist terror its own thing it's still
about 60% right-wing and bear in mind
that this includes a way broader
definition of domestic terror than any
of the other studies what if you don't
like any of these three studies well
then you can look at the National
Consortium for the study of terrorism
and responses to terrorism they maintain
profiles of individual radicalization in
the United States they look at
individuals radicalized since 1948 and
they have found that 40% are far-right
24 percent were Islamist 17% are far
left and 18% are what are called single
issue individuals who could be anywhere
on the political spectrum or even sort
of outside of it so no matter how you
want to catalog this no matter what set
of data you look at when you look at
radicalization in the United States when
you look at what movements are leading
people to commit violence in order to
try to achieve their political goals or
enforce what they see is their vision of
what the United States is or should be
it is at minimum a clear plurality
right-wing
and in some ways when we're looking at
for example extremist murders we're
talking about 90 plus percent right-wing
the normal responses that I hear when I
talk about this well they're not really
right-wing and this is a sort of a no
true Scotsman fallacy sort of thing
which we could delve into but listen I
mean these militia groups are right-wing
white nationalism is right-wing
sovereign Citizens movement is
right-wing extreme dogmatic religious
belief that leads you to violence
because you're angry that other people
don't follow your religion whether
that's Christianity or Judaism or Islam
that is also right-wing by any common
sense interpretation of what we're
talking about here so that one is a
common talking point you'll hear they're
not really right-wing hard to talk to
people who are going to make that
argument
what about ant Aoife right but ant Aoife
is a common one that you hear look at
the data big picture and Tifa is tiny
I am NOT a fan of anti feh I have
denounced anti FFA's methods to the
extent that an Tifa is a sort of
coherent and discrete group with methods
I'm against all of the stuff that has
been reported under the guise of an Tifa
and theif is tiny these are the broader
numbers you can't look at anecdotes both
sides do it is another common one that
you will hear where that's why we're
looking at the data to point out that
yes both sides do it in drastically
different proportion and to drastically
different degrees so we've got to take
the narrative back we don't have to be
afraid of talking about a guy who
attempted to firebomb a nice facility
where no one died or was even injured we
denounce it we criticize it we point out
that that person should be prosecuted to
the fullest extent of the law but we
don't lose the narrative the big picture
narrative that most political violence
in the United States is coming from the
right
do you have other data that contradicts
all four of these sets of data let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show